[Musique]
on va l'appeler le commandeur ça vient
de pommes d'emploi parce qu'à l'origine
c'est seulement lambres qu'il était
contenu à l'intérieur avant l'apparition
malcolm utilisé souvent le parfum sous
forme de programmes de hbo ont pas
récupérer la pommade du commandeur et la
mettre dans cette partie là avec le
vinaigre sur une petite éponge et ça va
permettre de diffuser l'auteur voilà
parce que le vinaigre va jouer le rôle
de solvants pour rendre un peu plus
liquides cette peau mate de pouvoir
diffuser l'odeur autour de la personne
portant nos plaies
[Musique]
le décor normand était très important et
si on regarde ici on va vraiment
d'hérens aux végétaux ce qui était assez
courant c'était de l'attacher à une
petite chaîne qui ont relié à une
baguette est comme ça en portait le
commandeur dans le creux de sa main fur
à mesure de la journée
quand déambulait dans la rue on avait
toujours le commandeur au creux de la
main
les plantes médicales sont très liés aux
parfums mais comme c'est la patte de la
découverte du nouveau monde
on va également utiliser les épices ou
les plantes un petit peu exotique qu'on
découvre à ce moment là bas pour
utiliser la vanille qui sera très très
apprécié dans les parfums on va utiliser
également le cacao
même le poivre blanc gris c'est une
déjection qu'on récupère du cachalot
qu'on utilise même encore aujourd'hui
pour la parfumerie la civette un petit
renard qu'on trouve surtout en afrique
en ethiopie on va utiliser les glandes
sexuelles de l'animal pour pouvoir faire
le parfum sexe à une odeur très prononcé
avec la civette on va ajouter d'autres
odeurs comme le jasmin ou la rose à
l'époque l'aude aura été sans cesse
sollicités l'atmosphère était saturé
d'odeur donc aujourd'hui ça ne
choquerait un peu plus qu'autrefois
c'était des odeurs plus normal
[Musique]